but airbnb is very interesting so this
guy frederick joseph who is he by the
way this guy frederick joseph
i like him author the black friend
forbes
under 30 marketer founder
former national surrogate for elizabeth
warren and bernie sanders fair enough
okay i like this guy because i i like
when people
invite you into their private lives to
make a public point
i like this i'm gonna read his whole
thread here on twitter he's trying to
get a refund from airbnb but i've
i've kind of done things like this i
give up because i want to just
insult the company and lie about what
happened
more than i actually want my money back
so i will you know i was famously in a
feud with dan kim the ceo over at mango
frozen yogurt um and then i would i
would say that i was raped in his
store and to me it was more important
because i just said let us make our own
yogurt because they still made it for
you at red mango you know
it was the heyday of self-serving this
[ __ ] would so then i just
started claiming i was being
raped in his store and there were rapes
happening in store
now that was more important to me than
any type of real change
do you see what i mean i was just trying
to use buzzwords to get attention
and to upset him i just want to upset
people
on social media more than i want to get
something
frederick joseph says we just drove
three hours my eight-year-old
wait a minute we just drove three hours
my eight-year-old brother for a getaway
okay another thing folks let's do the
grammar a little bit if we're going to
go out and call out a company and try to
make a little money which i have nothing
against
we just drove three hours my
eight-year-old brother for getaway in
the house we arrived at ended up having
seemingly satanic items and stuff for
witchcraft
rituals we had to leave because my
brother and the rest of us were
frightened but airbnb won't refund me
thread so now the first four pictures
are a
bahamat you know the uh so go up here
we got uh bahamut which is creepy
because it's got it's the goat
figure with the satanic pentagram and
then two children
looking up at bahamut and then next to
it is a picture of a goat
it is creepy the people that own this
house are probably satanists but many
satanists
aren't really
dangerous they're annoying
they're just people that tried to get
into something because they couldn't
figure anything else out they're like
i'm gonna put a bunch of candles around
my apartment
hopefully my life now has meaning
spoiler alert
it does not it does not
your embrace of the dark arts
notwithstanding go to work
please i rented this house to do writing
and spend time with my fiance brother
and cousin already i don't love that
idea
already i don't love the idea of you
going with your fiance brother and
cousin
to do right why are you going somewhere
to do writing
with three other people i don't believe
you're doing any writing
be honest i rented the house to work
out and i and i brought with me a cake
it doesn't make any sense i call out
companies
all the time but again i'm never looking
for a refund i'm just looking to get
someone in the company very nervous
about something
even for a split second and then they
find out i'm a comedian and then move on
but even for just a split second if
somebody at red mango has to read the
words
i was sexually assaulted
in your uh frozen yogurt shop
and i started doing this because i had
the chocolate sorbet
uh soft serve which had sorbitol in it
or sugar alcohol
which made me [ __ ] myself for 72 hours
like i had dengue fever
i basically had malaria okay it was not
nice
so then in order to kind of write the
wrong there
i then started tweeting at red mango
that i was viciously attacked i had to
delete the tweets i was in danger of
being
removed from twitter
i rented this house to do some writing
lie and spend time with my fiancee
brother and cousin it seemed like a nice
place pretty basic layout from the
listing
pictures below but as we drove up we
noticed there were no other houses in
the area
just rundown shacks and no phone signal
now what do you think ben ben you think
everything's satanic benjamin
every time we see a gnarled branch of a
tree ben thinks it's a scene at a true
detective
because he's always looking for satan
that's what he's always looking for
satan he just wants someone
to care about him even if that person is
trying to kill him
man just wants somebody other than his
lovely wife he just wants somebody out
there
to notice him besides me and he thinks
that person will be the dark lord
what if how what a lofty ideal you think
satan's trying to find you
she can go golf
does this seem weird to you that there
was nowhere else up there
no this is just people trying to be edgy
right i think so but let's go on we're
not done with this yet
okay okay when we walked up to the house
we noticed an animal skull hanging on
the outside of the house so i went
by the way i had an experience like this
had an airbnb montauk
and it was all native american stuff
yeah and i'm not
saying that native americans are satan
but they've got some animal skulls and
some things it was a motif
if the decor was not for me especially
because it was a white woman named sarah
okay now you know the way i feel about
cultural appropriation i think it's
[ __ ]
but i do get uncomfortable when a pretty
peppy white chick serves me chicken and
waffles
i want a mean middle-aged black woman
who's seen things
to hand me my chicken and waffles okay
and i want her to call me sugar
and then i want her to go in the back of
the restaurant and say
call me that big [ __ ]
i don't want some girl who went to
oberlin college
i don't want somebody named sarah
running out of shack and montauk and
[ __ ] you know thinking she's
pocahontas because she's through a bunch
of
[ __ ] quilts in it
[Music]
sarah you're the person that gave them
the smallpox blankets
you
when i walked to the bit when i walked i
went to the basement and found more
animal skulls and ritualistic floor
markings where were they did you have
photos of them i don't think so
and then i went up to the rooms to find
much more it is a creepy house a little
bit
as you walk through the two rooms you
found a bunch of imagery candles books
etc for rituals and what looked like
devil worship my brother was terrified
as were
we we called airbnb see i would have fun
if i was a satanist and i had this type
of house
it is creepy i would put a picture of
john podesta in the kitchen
and a picture of hillary clinton just
fun have a little fun with it
have a little fun with it we called
airbnb and told them we couldn't stay
there and explain the situation
keep going down we were told that we
couldn't receive a refund then they
spoke to the owner
who said they were just a few small art
pieces and that they could come remove
this was a lie it was a whole dm house
not a few things a bahamat
hidden behind a dead bird in a bag
there was also a bridge from the woods
behind the house to the back patio
needless to say we left because we are
black i don't know what that is
but i guess it's like a movie like
you're like this is a horror movie we're
black we know this works
but i get it black white asian
whatever pacific islander
norse people nordics whatever who's ever
out there
i understand this is creepy needless to
say we left because we were black and
not dealing
with something that was one advertised
completely different
would it be funny if you went to the
airbnb listing and they were like it
literally says
satan's lair you know there's some angry
airbnb persons like
it says satan's lair in the description
it says for losers who couldn't finish a
screenplay
that now have an interest in [ __ ]
satanism
weird german philosophers and the dark
arts
looks like a scene from hereditary
made the entire family feel unsafe all
of that to say this isn't how guest
should be treated i use airbnb
frequently and there are many reasons in
this situation which should warrant a
refund especially our safety mental
emotional health
so a lot of people uh we closed that out
but there's a lot of people on twitter
that are now like hey
[ __ ] crosses make me feel
uncomfortable
yeah i saw that i go to airbnb all the
time there's lots of religious artifacts
that make me feel uncomfortable why
should you
get a refund i walk in a house i see
buddhas i see
all kinds of statues that are not in
line with my religion
i don't know which side i come down on
this i think it's a little creepy
and then people are like welcome to the
country it's like that's not it
that's not the take dummy city guy
doesn't understand the country
it's a creepy house we would have stayed
in it yes
we would have stayed i would not have
asked for a refund um
[Music]
you know
i'd fill that house with a bunch of
people to make to satan satan is scared
stand-up comedians desperate
sad comics
you think uh human sacrifice is scary
have you ever seen
uh somebody over 40 to a tick tock that
ain't good either
that ain't nice either but i would have
stayed there i don't think i would have
asked for a refund
i don't believe in that black magic
where i don't think you can get me i'm
pr
baby i'm protected i'm protected the
light of the lord
i will redecorate that house in magga
[ __ ]
they'll come back to that airbnb they'll
come back to that airbnb
guess who's on the porch that looks like
tim dylan and candace owens we're
singing that martina mcbride song
he independent let freedom ring
let the wand of sing
let the whole world know that today
oscar's got an ak
it's a day of reckoning
what if i just replaced all the bahamats
with pictures of oscar
in a maga hat stop being a puss about
everything
so satan has owned a house they might
have sacrificed a few people out who
cares
i'm glad they're in the country whatever
on your beeswax